and with the holidays quickly
approaching millions of people are going
to be celebrating
differently this year it's really tough
to say what the majority of people will
be doing
many are thinking about what level of
risk they're comfortable with
is it just your immediate family is it
just your friends or celebrate with no
one at all
i'll be staying very close to home i
have family
out of town so i'm not going there and
they're not coming here
i feel like people are going to be doing
what they want you know
and regardless like when it comes to
family time you should take precautions
of course
planning early is key and don't assume
that everyone's going to be okay with
your decision
the cdc also recommends being outdoors
wearing a mask
sitting six feet apart and avoid singing
or shouting especially inside
so try and keep the music levels down so
people don't have to shout or speak
loudly to be heard
we asked you on twitter have your
thanksgiving plans change amidst the
pandemic
and this one was fairly split 45 percent
saying yep their plans have changed but
the majority 55 percent
said no